first of all i have to talk about the
green on green and green shoes i love
this whole look thank you so much it's
very much reminiscent of your video
maniac yes so good can we talk about how
much fun this video is it was a lot of
fun to do you know what
it was a lot of fun to
and then it was also like oh my god i'm
gonna be dancing for like eight hours
and i have no idea what i'm doing in
sparkly shoes the question is were those
shoes comfortable
hell no
no those shoes are like
those shoes are tiny like ballerina
swarovski crystal
saint laurent
uh steppers
and they hurt my feet but they're worth
it okay so how long did you prepare to
get all those dance moves down
you know we started
a couple weeks before
and it was one of those things that was
like okay like i'm gonna do this i'm
gonna get in front of the mirror i'm
gonna practice
and we did it a couple days
and then
i showed my wife
and
the director and the producer where i
was at
and
my mother-in-law has a saying don't show
a fool or a child
unfinished work
and
they uh they weren't too happy with
where i was okay so you had to step it
up i had to step it up but i also had a
freak out in between oh no
and then i rallied and i had a pretty
good attitude during the shoot but you
know it brings up some insecurity it's
like a lot of dancing to try to figure
out while i'm like parenting getting
ready for tour finishing an album like
there's a lot going on okay just so you
know without knowing that backstory you
look so confident that video you nailed
it thank you yeah and are people you
know kind of loving the fact that it's a
bit of a nod to the outcast song hey
yeah i think so i mean it's one of my
favorite
videos of all time yeah and i think hey
y'all there's so many we we had such a
vast inspiration board of different
videos from the 70s like the live
performance
um soul train type of stuff that was
happening in the 70s and wanted to
capture that magic yeah okay but so the
question of the day is now that i know
you had a bit of insecurity i don't know
if this is a fair question question of
the day who has better dance moves you
or andre 3000 andre
like not even close i'm going to vote
for you and not just because you're
sitting next to me you you worked it so
sweet it's just so this is so nice that
it's such a lie but it is so nice and i
will take it all right uh i do want to
talk to you about a pretty fun cameo
nardwar how'd that happen and and then
you mentioned ardmore in the song yes
and our word is
my dad
i knew it he is my father
nardwar
i
have known narward since like maybe
2010-ish
that was our first interview before
anyone knew who i was and i was like why
are you interviewing me like literally
no one knows me
uh and
you know he interviewed us later on he's
just been super cool i dm'd him was like
yo narwhar what do you think
and uh and he was down so we got a film
crew up to vancouver he definitely
wasn't coming to seattle that was like
out of the question well i think the
border i don't trust i just don't feel
like nardwar leaves that off and he's
like
vancouver he like sticks to canada yeah
and south by southwest and then canada
and then that's it yes so he's excited
about to be in the video i think he's
pumped yeah he was the whole crew loved
him he had a great vibe it's star wars i
love it it was just fun for me i was
like i used to watch them on much music
all the time so that was kind of like a
fun throwback yeah uh another song that
your fans are loving is chant right now
we just spoke to tones and i and she
basically said it was a dream to
collaborate with you yeah what was that
whole process like
tones is
just such a good person she is
on tour with us now
she is
just like she's in the room she's
hilarious she's so talented i love her
she's like you know a sister to me and
uh she absolutely killed the record yeah
how proud are you of that song
i'm super proud of that song um
we've been playing it live at the shows
on this tour
and uh you know i think it captured the
moment and i think that whatever
it is you're trying to convey with the
record you want to capture that spirit
like maniac captures a certain spirit
chant captures a different spirit yeah
and i think that we did that what was it
like for you also speaking of maniac
reuniting with ryan lewis i mean it's
been five years since you guys
collaborated was the chemistry still
there
yeah ryan
ryan is great i mean
whenever i'm with ryan it feels like
i was with him two days ago yeah um
you know he still is someone that
is you know and we don't obviously talk
as much as like we did when we were
working together every day for a decade
but like
um
you know he's still one of my best
friends he knows me better than most
people in this world so
he is always going to be up there and
he's always like a brother to me okay so
how is the tour going right now magic
dragons come on that's awesome it's
going great i mean late nights
not even really no okay
it was just last night we decided to go
to the club last night oh yes all right
yeah
that doesn't happen often
and uh
so we went to the club that's fun and we
went early nice we went at 10 30. that's
pretty early
which uh i mean for one the fact that
toronto has like a club scene on a
sunday night like this is like better
than any club in seattle on a sunday
night okay i don't know the club scene
here i'm not cool so yeah i don't know
the club scene in seattle so i'm
comparing it to something that i have no
idea about but it seemed pretty popping
yeah it was a good time but we we got
there at 10 30 and uh yeah there was no
one there it was perfect there's no one
there it was freezing so you could dance
and not get hot nice they were playing
songs with no one else there was
fantastic amazing now that you're
confident with your dance moves right i
mean i busted out so many of those moves
there's so much choreo happening this is
what maniac did to you yeah you're now
this person i'm like you guys
i have some things to show people
i love that um is it wild see that it's
been 10 years since thrift shop
yes does that feel like it was like
yesterday because i know that changed
everything it did it changed everything
does it feel like i mean in some ways it
feels like 10 years yeah
it feels like a while ago there's a lot
of life that has been lived between now
and thrift strap i think
it feels maybe more like eight okay but
it's close shape off the two years yeah
about two years
but it's um yeah i mean that record
changed at all and um
i'm forever grateful for
for thrift shop and what it showed the
rest of the world and the journey that
it started us on so
um
you know i'm excited to celebrate it
this year it's kind of this moment of
like
extended moment of reflection because
i'm getting asked about it a lot so
i'm i'm forced to think about it
and um in the best way so it's been nice
do you have good memories when you think
of that song when you hear it when
you're performing it yeah i do i mean
they played it in the club last night
and it was like you know there was they
know you were
they came out with the sign with all the
bottles
and it was just us in the club that's
amazing
i mean like an hour and a half later it
was packed but like when they brought up
the bottles it was just uh it was it was
great i have a great tick tock in my
head about you know no one being there
um but they played thrift shop and there
was a time where i would have been like
oh my god i can't hear this song right
now and last night it was like
let's turn up it sounded great so
yeah
when you think of the elm heist
how part are you of that album and what
you wanted to say and what you got out
there to the fans
uh i'm super proud of the heist i think
that it captured again like a moment in
time
i think that what was great about the
heist is that
we had a long time to work on it you
know it was like
we worked on the heist for over three
years
but some of that stuff was even longer
yeah you know some of you know i started
writing thrift shop and bits and pieces
in like
2008 so
um
yeah it was a record with thrift shop
with same love with can hold us with
white walls and so many other album cuts
on it um i think it's just a body of
music that's going to withstand the test
of time forever and that's something to
be proud of you know when you think back
on your career what does being on tour
look like now aside from
party nights in toronto
um
you know it all depends where i'm at
right like
europe is very different than north
america is very different than
south america
asia um it all depends you know crowds
are completely different this is um
um
uh a run where we're opening for imagine
dragons and they're massive yes
they're like the biggest rock band in
the world right now perhaps
i don't have the data but it seems like
that
like that's accurate yeah
um
so you know it's it's getting in front
of a lot of new fans it's my fans
it's um going on a little bit earlier
than i'm used to
and it's fun because i have to work for
the crowd you know like i go to europe
and i kind of step on stage and i'm just
like hello hello
and um this one's a little bit like you
know there's people there that are like
i'm here to hear radioactive who are you
so that's fun i like that that's a good
challenge i like that i know it's i the
challenge is is something that i embrace
are you going to do anything for the
10th anniversary of a thrift shop
well we've been talking about it for
about a year yeah i don't know if we are
okay i mean yes we will do something
yes
we are working on stuff
yes we are i like the teas i feel like
that was an easy canada scoop maybe you
say that to everyone but i'm gonna
pretend you just said that to us
so much fun getting to talk to you
likewise you're awesome
you